now wait is finally over
thousands of car fans descended on Lake
Constance in southern Germany recently
for tuning world Boden's a among the
highlights is this VW type 147 also
known as free Baline the completely
revamped former mail van was the winner
of last year's European tuning showdown
silence when shows tunes us into the
three big trends in 2015 the first is
the stance look the perfect combination
of wheel offset tire and wheel arch a
proper stance look involves major
modifications to the suspension in
addition to the low body setting you
also alter the angle or camber of the
wheels so that they're slanted and
there's another trend currently hitting
Europe from overseas despite a wide body
you have the classic variety which are
laminated on and where you don't notice
immediately and the really hot thing
from Japan and the US are bolt on body
kits extremely wide bumpers with
extended wheel arches the visible bolts
are intentional for that ROM motorsports
look what is a relative ahora dime spot
optic estaba a blue sky and those wider
dimensions come straight from
motorsports this cadet see is intended
for mountain rallies all that matters
here is performance
but if you're planning on giving your
regular road-going car a makeover like
this they're in mind a couple of factors
tips orchids tuning expert Sydney
Huffman recommends you derma fight take
those German virtues even further look
at this for example I'd it's all I
seeing somebody that he was so snide and
you have to make a cut here don't do
what the Americans are Japanese to make
a wheel arch conserve it by cutting it
out with an angle grinder naked
long-lasting Kansai vidas Maka's na hoti
hold on fuzzy don't underestimate body
cavity ceiling if moisture gets in it
will rust and then the whole project
will have no point because of what it
will cost you Kostya wats it also costs
a pretty penny to widen a fiat 500 and
fit a Lamborghini engine in the back but
all in all extreme specimens like this
are more the exception than the rule at
tuning world
that's the third trend explains our
tuning expert our high performance
versions of regular vehicles like a go
far ford focus RS r AMG Mercedes they
get individual suspension upgrades and
top caliber wheels and often great
breaks from a Porsche or a Lamborghini
which can keep the kind of pace the car
has in check you can break very quickly
and avoid an accident that comes in kind
of nasty kind of fast but where is the
general trend headed old school retro or
modern cars
to answer that question try this baby
the original mobile time machine that
starred in the movie back to the future
complete with flux capacitor bog machine
and destination time menu january second
2025 I've caught it from Los Angeles in
2010 and the people that built it for
universal studios no it wasn't for sale
I contacted them and asked them to build
one for me and they said we couldn't do
it but if I waited long enough I could
have the one that Universal Studios was
using so I was very lucky to obtain it
outside there's plenty of action in the
Gymkhana drift Cup it's a contest of
handling the pits drivers directly
against each other until mirror image
courses side-by-side first one to
complete the course and the mandatory
maneuvers wins
BMW's and badged cars are a popular
choice for the face on and back inside
beamers are in big demand to from the
slick but sporty to the more vivacious
works of art and their own right
as is this BMW driven by Tanya Beck it's
multicolored and cuddly it's got its own
cozy sweater completely crocheted in
wool tanya is proud of her little woolly
i bought the car in the winter and it
was totally frozen over i had the idea
of crocheting the metal gear knob and
why not the mirror covers and the roof
rails and eventually I did the entire
car wrapping with wool instead of decals
another new trend perhaps and the car is
in fine working condition by the way for
performance oriented car tuners however
probably not their cup of tea nyanza
I've had loads of people asking me how
much the car weighs now and how much
will that is that then got me interested
so I put it on the scales and it
actually weighed sixty kilos more sexy
kill oh man
you